And
we're live. We're live.
Welcome.
What wow. April 8.
Good afternoon.
Welcome to pod 256
number one 11.
1 1 1.
K. We are live.
How are you doing today?
Man, I'm doing good.
I'm doing really good. I've been Good deal.
You know what's tough when you're working on so much fun stuff is
picking which one to work on.
Right? And that's that's not the worst problem to have. So
Well, and it's not really like work if you enjoy what you do. Right? That's right.
That's right. The work is trying to figure out which one of these amazing projects I'm gonna work on.
And then, of course It's like when you You get into a you get into these chats and someone's like, dude, could you do this? And you're like, oh my gosh. We could totally do this. And then you just forgot all about what you were gonna do today. Then you get nerd sniped. Nerd sniped. It's real
Yep. When you're That and trying to figure out, like, what to call a project is
is a lot of work.
That's right. Naming things is hard.
Yeah.
When I when I hear about the thing I got nerd sniped on like this morning.
Yeah. What was it?
So there's this guy in the OSMU chat, Just Huddle. He's a he was one of the first people that ever messaged me about the Bitaxe like years ago, and we were chatting and he was like
He said this morning, he was like, you know what I miss? Is those little USB minor sticks.
Like you could just They didn't have a fan. They were just simple. You could just plug them in.
I initially was like,
those are dumb because
a lot of times they required special USB ports because they draw so much current and you had to load some goofy software
to run it.
But then we got thinking about it and it's like we could fix all these problems. We could make
a USB stick that works in any USB port, right, and has like Right. You know, maybe hundreds of Gigahash
and,
you know, it's passive cooled and could do it for really cheap. Like, maybe this could be like the
the $20
USB miner stick and just went down this rabbit hole. And then
K1 stepped in, who he's a amazing engineer, and he's like, oh, you could use these new parts I've been looking at. And, yeah, he just started going down this rabbit hole, got it all, like, diagrammed out. I was like, man, should we make this?
And then the
comment was it, like, it needs to be cheaper than a latte.
Latte prices are going up a lot. I bought, like, a $12 latte at the JFK Airport.
Holy cow.
Yeah. I didn't even really realize what was going on because it was, you know, it was red eye. I got in early, and I was just like, coffee, and I got it. And then I looked at my receipt, I'm like, wait. What?
What just happened? What just happened to me? Oh, well. Whatever.
But,
yeah, the comment was it should be cheaper than a latte. So I was like, is this gonna be called Bid X Latte? You know?
Dude. Creamy smooth,
tasty,
easy. That's a good name.
So
So now you're saying there's an open source project called Bitaxe Latte?
Well,
I guess, yeah, there is.
I mean, it
hasn't
I I did go disturbingly far down this rabbit hole and and pencil it all out, but I haven't
published any source yet. So I guess it's not an open source project yet. It's an open source idea.
Alright. See, but still, this is amazing.
Publish it for sure,
But just the fact that,
like, this can all come together and then just be
made publicly available and then anyone can grab it and build it.
It's a
it's a beautiful thing. You just don't get that in close
and proprietary
other company settings, you know? You don't, you don't. I'm so stoked to be working in this field too because it's
things like this will happen at a company where you're talking to a couple coworkers and you're like, oh my gosh, we could do this, and you're working on this thing, and then inevitably some manager is like, no,
don't waste any more time on that, we're not doing it. But here, there's no one saying don't do it, so you can really go down the rabbit hole. But then the cool thing is you can talk with other people about it and get amazing input, and, you know, it just might happen.
Yeah. And insight from people that, like, otherwise would be working for the competitor that you'd never even know existed.
Yes. Yes. That's right.
So it's fun stuff. I also I guess we're on the topic of just
goofy little
projects that I got nerdsniped into. I actually just finished one.
This
right here,
this very small little board.
Is that the Atit board? No.
It looks similar. It looks similar. It's about the same size, maybe a little bit smaller.
Okay.
This is suffering from not a good name yet. It's called the AC adapter.
But
basically, has a four pin connector on one side and a USB C connector on the other side, and it allows you to plug an AC Infinity duct fan
into any fan connector port like a Bitaxe or Oh. A Amlogic
Bitmain Antminer control board or
whatever has a standard four pin fan port and lets you control one of those big duct fans.
I feel like the name Infinity needs to be incorporated into that product.
Yeah.
Fanfinity.
I don't know. This this is a tough
is the toughest part of a project.
Yeah. I'll sleep on it. Yeah. Let me know. Let me know. Okay.
But, yeah, it works.
I got it working on the Amlogic control board, which is kinda neat.
Awesome. So that means you don't have to use the stock
Antminer fans.
Right.
And you can just hook up
what are you doing like a like six inch duct fan or like
I've got an eight inch one. It was Eight inch. Okay. It was gifted to me. I was because I've been doing a lot of work with the
Aminer s 19 j pro with the control boards and such. And so I have this thing, like, on my desk right next to me. And these fans, even when it's underclocked, just sound like,
you know, angry hornets. It's terrible.
Right. And I was just complaining about that, and someone's like, you know what? I'm gonna give you my AC Infinity Duct fan. They're significantly quieter.
And so
And you just need the one. Right? You're you don't need one on both sides like the stock ant miner fans. Yeah. Yeah. It moves a lot of air. A lot of air. Do you run it on the input side or the output side? Like, is it drawing air through the miner or pushing it?
I think you're supposed to do it on the input side.
So it pushes air through the miner. Yeah. Because then I think Okay. You don't have the hot air going through the the duct fan.
That makes sense.
I actually connected mine to the exhaust due to the way I have the miner set up on my desk,
but that was just for development.
I also know that if you are screwing around with you and you set it to a 100%
like, fan speed, it will blow absolutely everything off your desk. Just like everything went flying across my office. They they move a lot of air. Yeah. Do you know what the CFM rating is?
I don't.
I don't. Should I look it up?
Might be interesting to know. Let's see. Let's see.
Is the AC Infinity
Cloudline
s eight?
Because I think the stock AmpMiner fans, if I remember correctly, were doing like three
or 400 CFM
each.
It says 807
CFM.
Yeah.
Sounds
great.
Yes. It literally does. It sounds much better. Like, when it's at a 100%, you can definitely hear it, but mostly you just hear, like, all the other shit blowing off your desk.
Whereas the
Antminer
s 19,
like, muffin fans, they just
they're screamers. Man Right. Hate those things. Yeah.
And it's like
they're
they they can become, like, tolerable. Like, you can get used to it, but it's when they, like, start shifting
their RPMs
to accommodate for, like, fluctuations in temperature.
That's when it, like, starts to get really annoying, like, when they're when they're con because that tone changes. Yes.
Yes. I feel like before my time, you guys used to have that sound of the fans ramping up at the get beginning of pod two fifty six, and it was a little bit, like, PTSD inducing.
That's when we had our producer, Tom, helping us out with the show,
and he put that sound bite together. Yeah.
It's
it's loud.
Yeah.
So the cool one of the things about using this AC Infinity fan adapter is that
you need to have
firmware that you control. Right? Like
Right. It won't work with stock firmware or any of the aftermarket firmware because
the AC Infinity fan does not report its RPM back.
So
a lot of the firmware will just, it'll shut off if the fans aren't working.
Right. Or, you know, if they they aren't reporting an RPM, like their speed.
Yeah. Yeah. It'll tell the miner to shut off because it thinks, like, something's broken. Yeah. So you need a firmware that you can say, I still wanna control the fans, but I don't wanna like read back the RPM,
which
I don't think exists.
I know some of the aftermarket firmware you can say like immersion mode or something where just like forget the fans.
Mhmm. But I believe in that case it will not continue to control the fans. It just, like, does no fan stuff.
Well, that's where Mugena comes in. Right? Exactly.
Yeah. Yes.
Yes. Mugena,
in just the little hack version that I made of it, controls it
very nicely.
That's awesome. And it's not hard to do, and, you know, you can have a different mode. Or you actually also need a slightly different PWM frequency to ideally control the AC Infinity fans, so you can just do that. Like,
imagine a world where you have a firmware and you wanna do something and you can just do it.
Right.
It opens up a lot of possibilities.
I think
I I mean, I don't know what it'll take for. I feel like there's a there's, like, a tipping point in which Mugena goes viral.
Yeah. And
not long thereafter,
no one will tolerate the closed firmware solutions. Like, once you, like, once you see it and the possibilities and what it can do, it's like you you can't tolerate
closed firmware anymore and just being stuck with what the manufacturer
gave you.
Yeah. I mean, it seems so obvious to me. Maybe that's because I've just been already experiencing the benefits of it. But I think you're you're absolutely right. At some point,
it's just gonna go viral for everyone from little home miners to, you know, the big industrial miners. And they're like,
how did we live with this
Exactly. Before.
Yeah.
And it it's like
people trying to code today without AI.
Like, I saw a developer
say on Twitter the other day, something to the effect of,
you know, tried
manually coding again today and just can't believe we actually used to work this way a year ago without AI.
Like
Yes. It's like once once those tools come out and those capabilities
get unlocked
and you
realize
how much more efficient,
customizable,
like, just all around better the tool has made your performance,
you can't go back.
Yeah. You can't go back. Right? It's gonna be like
like ride your horse to work or something.
Maybe you do it for fun or sport or something, but yeah,
once you see the amazing productivity
that you can get with this stuff, yeah, there's no going back.
And and the flexibility and the ability and just, you know, like having this idea or having like a conversation with someone in a chat room and then like just being able to go and try it, like uninhibited,
nothing holding you back. You just have an idea. Everything you need is at your fingertips. You can try it and just get, like, instant feedback
from the real world, like, if it's working or not and if it's a viable idea.
And it's so exciting too because it's just like you're like, I have these ideas. I wanna do this. And then you're, like, working towards it, and it's happening. It's not like Mhmm. I have this idea. I wanna do this. Now I'm fighting with some sort of weird compiler error or, like, syntax thing for, you know, some
boilerplate code stuff that you just forgot.
Right.
This actually,
this
AC adapter
board, I didn't like vibe code the whole thing, but the design of it was vibe coded. I put it into a ChatGPT,
what I wanted to do. It helped me reverse engineer
the protocol to the AC Infinity fan because that's not public.
Oh, interesting. And it helped me lay out the circuit to do it.
I still had to take some, you know, readings with my multimeter and confirm what the pin out was and stuff like that. But
actually, found out it was kinda neat because I was struggling with what like, what's the pin out for
this AC Infinity connector? Because it uses a USB C connector, but it it's not USB at all. It's just
normal fan control signals but on a USB cable and connector.
Oh, interesting. So I was like kinda struggling with it, like trying to take my multimeter and like stick it into the USB C connector. And then I was like, alright, well I'm gonna open up the fan. There's this little box on the side with four screws,
a little compartment that you open it up
to see what's going on in there. And I open it up, and there's a bunch of wires, and I'm kinda looking at it. And then I randomly
looked at the inside of the lid
that I had just taken off,
it's right there. The schematic. Diagram? It has a diagram on the inside of the lid. How cool is that?
And that's the
okay. So that's that's not necessarily, like, the protocol that they have closed source, but it gives you a good idea of, like, the pinout of that cable. Yeah. Yeah. So that I could wire it up to this board, like, you know, know which signals are which. Right. It was pretty neat.
That's awesome.
And then I put that, of course, into
AI tool and Yeah. The voltages that I had measured and was like, how should I hook this up? And it came up with the schematic. It didn't give me like a traditional schematic. I got this kinda goofy
like
block diagram,
which I posted all of it on the GitHub for it. But
this goofy block diagram, but it suggested parts and everything. So then I just manually converted that into a a real schematic and got the boards made.
Just amazing.
I I don't know which is more amazing if, like, how well AI is helping you
speed up your process or the fact that you reverse engineered
the first bid acts without any AI support whatsoever.
It took so long, and now it's just like, oh, man. Dude.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's a wild world. This stuff is moving real fast now.
Right.
Blocks
and
solo miners,
what's been going on this week?
Yeah. The last few days have been really cool for solo miners.
Yeah. Mugena or get the fuck out, says d plus plus. Correct. Mugena is gonna take over the world.
But speaking of taking over the world, there was three,
solo mined blocks
in the last
four or five days.
That's amazing. Yeah. Really exciting.
The first one was to CK Pool.
That and it was with a
you know, we don't know exactly what minor it was, but I think it was kind of somewhere around 270.
So that kinda says it's like a,
you know, a recent
s 21 or what's minor or something like that.
So that but that's cool. They, you know, they solo minded to CK Pool. But
then I think two days after that,
the hosted public pool hit its first block with the nerd Octaxe
Yeah. Which was really exciting. It was really exciting.
How long has public pool been how long has have they been hosting that instance without a block find?
Well, years.
Yeah.
Yeah. So
public pool, the software,
this is the sixth block
for public pool the software, but this is the first one for the hosted version
at public-pool.io.
Right.
And, you know, it which is it's been it's been when it first started, it obviously didn't have that much hash rate. So it's been slowly ramping up, but, I think it's at
well, let's see. What is it at? Let's do web.public.io.
It is at
it's like in the neighborhood of 50
now.
Mhmm. Obviously, that ramped up quite a bit after the exciting block find.
But
yeah. So it, you know, it's it is overdue, I think, for a block on public pool. But nonetheless, it's very exciting to see.
There's
nerd octaxes on there, which is the miner that found this block.
17,000
bit axes,
2,000 nerd q axes.
There are 79,000
nerd miners
Dude. For a grand total of
700.
That's insane. Yeah. That is insane. But it it was really cool. It was really cool. Public
Pool is doesn't take any fees.
Ben has just been kinda hosting this out of the the
the goodness of his heart, the the sort of nerd snipe geek dom that has been
so he's been it's been really cool that he has run this for so long.
It's, you know, at a total loss to him personally because he doesn't take a fee like other solo pools.
Right.
And Ben, who who made public pool, is also a core contributor to the Bidax. He did a lot of Axe OS.
He's a Bidax manufacturer.
He's been involved. And so as a result, public pool is the default
pool that Bidaxes, that new Bidaxes mine to.
Mhmm.
So at this point, he can't turn it off because then all those people that haven't changed their pool address would be
wondering what happened.
Right.
Well and it's like when you come out with a new
pool software,
there's always kinda this, like,
moment where you're holding your breath because you
you can test it
and you can theorize and, you know, extrapolate that it's gonna work, but you don't really know for sure that it works until you see a block find on main net. Yeah. Right? And that's like what we went through with HYDRA pool, and we're in that moment of, like, holding our breath with HYDRA POOL right now. Like, you know, is it, like, really, really gonna work? Like, it should. Like, all signs indicate that it should, but you just never really get that confirmation
until you see the block find. And I think that's kinda like what's
been happening with public pool for, you know, multiple years now that he's been hosting this. And it's like, man, like, like, the Umbral version
found, what, four blocks? This is the fifth
public pool block,
but just the first on the hosted instance. The sixth public pool block. Yeah. So Six public pool. Self hosted versions,
Umbral,
etcetera, have
proven out the software. But then Yeah. I mean, it's like you never really, really know Yeah. Until it happens on your specific installation.
So okay. I wanna read this tweet from Altair Technology.
This was posted
let's see.
April 2.
Just hours
well, we'll get into that. So this was posted on April 2.
And Altair writes, at 45 petahash per second, public pool is statistically expected to find a block every five months. It's been running for over two years, yet the public instance has still found no blocks. SoloCKPool,
on the other hand, consistently delivers results, 16 solo blocks in 2025 alone, many won by regular hobbyist
miners with small setups.
The Bitcoin network is secured by miners actually finding
and building on blocks. A pool that does not contribute to block production secures nothing and pays out nothing. For most small miners doing lottery style solo mining, CK Pool is the better choice.
What a dick.
And then just hours later,
Public Pool actually finds a block
on their hosted instance.
Thus
It
was amazing.
You cannot could not have planned this any better.
Dude, this was on my clock, it was at, like,
10:30PM
at night.
So
it was, like, within hours,
public pool found that blog. This is like some Jim Kramer style stuff. Right? It's like Yeah. Totally. I there was a bunch of comments were like, oh, Altair, like, rip on my public on my miner next, please.
Right.
Yeah.
But, I mean, that's
I like, I I don't even understand, like, what the point of, like, making a comment like that is, and I'm just I'm glad that he
got slapped in the face. You know? That's karma for you. Yeah. Even without the block find, it's it's a nonsensical post because he says 45 petahash for multiple years,
but that's not the case. Which isn't true. It hasn't been 45 petahash for multiple years. So No.
You know, that's that's only more recently. So
Yeah. You know, it might not
be overdue.
And then he's comparing it to CK Pool, which I don't think reports their total hash rate. Maybe they do. I don't know. It's significantly I think more they do.
It's significantly more
hash rate on CK pools. So of course they're gonna find more blocks.
Right.
I don't Well, and it's just sad that you have,
you know, a project like Public Pool, which is basically
just a, like, a public
contribution.
No you know, zero fees, not taking any fees from anybody, just running a pool so that the the bid access have something to mine too out of the box,
so people have a pool that they can test with.
Just running it for the good of the community that wants to try Bitcoin mining and for no other reason. And yet you've got someone out there just talking shit about it like that. It's just pathetic.
Yeah.
It is pathetic. And the story behind Public Pool is really pretty cool. I posted this about this on Twitter, but this was, you know, several years ago,
when the Bidax was just starting.
And
back then, people don't don't remember this, but CK Pool, which is open source software that anyone can run, but back then CK Pool was not compatible with the latest Bitcoin Core.
You couldn't just download and run it.
I think, Konkolovacs
Right. Had taken a break from maintaining it, and he confirmed this on the Twitter thread eventually.
But, there
was a change to get block template in Bitcoin Core, and CK Pool had not been updated for for a matter of years.
So
there wasn't really any solution for someone who just wanted to mine to their own node.
Right.
You know, you could
I actually did this. It was a it was a pretty small change to CK Pool to get it to work with Bitcoin Core, And I did that and, like, posted a fork of the repo. But,
again, that was just, you know, you had to, like, screw with it for a while
Right. To get it to work. There was no
turnkey
way to mine to your own node.
No. There was it was next to impossible unless you were, like, a developer. Yeah. And I I was, like, struggling with that for a long time. Like, dude, there's, like you know, leading up to
creating the foundation,
that
fueled my desire to have, like, a one click deployable mining pool. Because, like,
wanted to mine to my own node and, like, do it the quote, unquote right way, but there just wasn't
any practical way for someone that didn't have a really in-depth technical understanding to do it.
And the the like, Bitcoin talk, which was, I guess, the premier way that people learned about this stuff, if you went on there, you can see there's several posts from people that are like, you know, I wanna try mining to my own node. The consensus was like, no, don't do it. It's not worth it. Like, there's a variety of excuses given, but like, no, don't do it. And it didn't help that the software was
incredibly difficult to use.
So
that that was kind of what Public Pool was born out of.
It was,
you know, Ben, who was an earlier an early
developer working on the Bidax was
like,
alright. I'm just gonna make it. And he he did it really quickly too, which was amazing. And it it was really helpful because now you could mine to your own node. But then furthermore, it was set up so that we could test and debug ESP Miner in the Bidax.
Mhmm. Right? It's really helpful. Like, we did this when we were testing
Mugena and Ember one.
We were able to instrument
HydroPool to see what's happening on the Stratum server side.
That makes it very that makes it a lot easier to develop a Stratum client when you can see what the server is saying.
Yeah. Exactly. So that was the same deal with with Public Pool. And,
yeah. It was just really cool, and it's just put out there, open source,
available for everyone. Someone came and took it and wrapped it up for Umbral, so now it's a single click install. Same thing for Start Nine.
Yep.
And, yeah.
It's like a huge win for the community.
And it's the same licenses as CK Pool and CG Miner, by the way. So I don't know where
Avril
what his specific beef with this is. But
Well, I think he just he doesn't like it because it's associated with Bidax and two fifty six Foundation.
I mean, well, I mean,
via via Bitaxe. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. I think that's what it is.
I'm looking at solostats.ck.org,
and I think the total hash rate on The US server
is a 142 petahash right now. Okay.
So it's So, like, a 100 petahash over what he was saying in that tweet.
Yeah. It's like three times the hash rate. Right? Yeah. Sorry. A 100 pet hash more than what public pool had Yeah. At the time of that tweet.
So,
I mean, they will solve blocks more often on CK Pool.
Right. No surprise there.
And I I mean, I wanna make it very clear. Like, no beef with CK Pool. Like,
it's an awesome service.
It's open source. It's proper GPL. Like, it's I love CK Pool, and doctor Khan Kolovus is a boss. So Indeed. Yeah. There's no beef there whatsoever.
And I think
doctor Khan Kolovas,
he said this in the the Twitter thread that he had. This, like, he's got no beef with public pool either. We need more options,
and the more the merrier. Yeah. So Right.
You know, we don't Well, like
I mean, c he
what did he do? He he didn't did he make CG miner?
He did. Yeah.
Yeah. And so, like,
basically,
the entire Bitcoin mining ecosystem as we know it was built on the work that he provided for free. Mhmm. And then
Bitmain stole and made firmware out of CGminer.
And,
you know, that's been powering, like, 80% of the Bitcoin network.
Yeah. I mean, I think it probably more than 80%. Right? Because we know we know Bitmain stole it, and then
MicroBT,
what's mine here, is not really any different than Bitmain. So they probably did too. We've seen remnants of it in
Kanans,
minor, binaries.
I think everyone just used it because it was out there.
Right. I think the majority of pools have probably been built on
some kind of version of CK pool as well.
I mean, e even HYDRA pool, like, it has been heavily influenced by what we found in CK Pool's code.
Yes. This this speaks to the benefit or the the
usefulness of reference designs.
Right.
Because, you know, it's like it's
really helpful in developing something to see a working example, and, people have done that. It's obviously a shame that a lot of those didn't
abide by the
the GPL
that was attached to them like they're legally obligated to, but Right.
Well, and leave it to like
Luke Dash Junior being one of the only people I've ever been able to find
publicly
saying negative things about Khan Kolovas,
like despite all those contributions that he's made.
So it just goes to show you what Luke's character is like. So interesting story. This was many years ago, but I definitely remember this. I remember I wanted to mine to my own node and I was researching it and I was reading on Bitcoin talk and
I had tried CK pool and it was not working. It would colonel panic. And
then I came upon
Luke Dash Junior's project BFGminer.
Mhmm. Which was very out of date at this point.
BFGminer
appears to be like a it's a combination client
and server.
And I actually got that working. I was able to mine to my own node using BFGminer
as the stratum server, but it was
really difficult to
configure and get that working.
So
I assume that is the basis of
Luke's,
I don't know, beef or derogatory comments towards Konkolovas
is that they had competing open source projects at the same time.
Yeah. The I mean, know the beef goes way back,
but I think
c CG minor was out first, but Luke will try and tell you that his that BFG minor was out first.
But, like, the, like, the git history is there, and you can see that it wasn't. Yeah.
I mean, is the kind of
online
arguments I'd rather see is like,
no, my project is more open source than yours.
Like, let's go. Let's
do that.
Yeah. Right. And we can all battle to see who's the most open source and who has the most features and who is the, you
know, providing the most usefulness.
That's funny. That's Yeah. Good call. We'll take that every day over the current situation, which is
quite abysmal.
Right.
So yeah, we had CK, we had public pool, and then did we talk about the third block that was found this week? The third block was
a pool run by
It's
called the Node Runners pool.
Node Runners is a
I think it's a group of people that advocate for and help
people run their own nodes.
They also run their own
mining solar mining pool, I believe based on CK Pool.
And, yeah, they hit a block with a Nerd QX.
I wanna say that was yesterday,
maybe the day before. I think so.
Yeah. I think it was yesterday. So that was their first.
Yeah,
there was kind of a neat tweet where
the
guy who runs Node Runner's pool, who also is the guy who made the BTC clock,
he
was like
it was something like, oh my god.
The pool the solo pool I run just hit a block.
Just obviously very surprised and excited, and then Twitter just blows up with excitement. And I'm
sure that
that has convinced a lot of people to take their small bid axes and NerdQ axes and smaller miners and and
do
do solo mining with them. Right.
Do you know if they,
like, just do a straight up PPL and S split,
or do they have, like, one of those more elaborate
payout
schemes like Parasite Pool has?
Where, like, the miner that I think in Parasite Pool's model, like the miner that hits the block gets 1 Bitcoin, and then the rest is divvied up on a PPLNS basis.
Let's check. I believe yes. It is a pure solo mining pool. So no PPLNS,
and they do not take any fees.
So
Oh, 0%
fees? 0% fees. It's all or nothing solo mining.
Cool. I have not double checked. I should double check this, but if
what they say
is true,
then your
address should be the only one in the Coinbase.
Yeah.
Which
I got, an email from
a user this week.
I I think they were, like, a new Bitaxe user. Will you talk briefly about
an update that was made in Axe OS recently where
it
will
give you a message at the top of your interface window about
whether you're at whether you're included in the Coinbase reward and what that percentage is. Can you can you talk about that a little bit?
Yeah. Yeah. So there there was some drama a while back with the discovery of some,
like, solo pools that they claimed they were Bitcoin solo mining pools, but they actually weren't.
So one of them was actually mining Bitcoin Cash,
and another one I think was a straight up scam where they say you're solo mining
but
your
your payout address was not in the Coinbase at all.
In fact, we just found one the other day that is like that where it says it's solo mining but then when you actually look at the work that's delivered to you over Stratum,
it does not have your address in the Coinbase at all. Meaning if you sell off a block you get nothing.
And it's not like a PPNS pool, you're not getting paid out for shares either. So they're just straight up scams.
So this was happening.
And so the idea was,
you know, can we add something to Axe OS on the Bid Axe that that helps you identify this type of scam?
And,
yeah, we can. Right? Because we have
you know, as your worker name, you put your payout address.
And
for a solo mining pool, that address
should be in the Coinbase of the work that you get.
If it's not, something's wrong.
Yeah. Because then that means you're
working on templates
that
in the event of a block find will not result in you getting paid out anything. Correct. Or they'll result in you getting paid out nothing. Yes.
Yes. That's that's the kinda cool thing about Stratum is that Stratum sends you
the
the template, which is a sort of it's a block header,
and that's what you mine. And so if you if your miner
finds a nonce,
a golden nonce that, you know, finds a block over the difficulty,
that's actually what's going to submit it be submitted. And so that Coinbase
is what is actually going to get paid out for that block.
And if you're solo mining,
then you
you want to have your address in that that Coinbase reward because you're doing sort of all or nothing mining. Right? You're not getting paid incrementally for every share. You're getting paid
some large percentage of the block reward when you solve a block.
And so you can you can you can fact check these solar pools
and check to see if your address is indeed in there and you can see what percentage it is. And so
the feature was added
to,
Axe OS and ESP Miner, the the software that runs a bit axe to just check and see is your payout address in the Coinbase of the work that you're receiving.
And if it's not,
an error, a warning
is shown that says
your PAI address is not in the Coinbase.
Now
it's a little confusing because
if you're not solo mining,
like if you're mining to
ocean or if you're mining to
brains or for some messed up reason you're mining the ant pool,
your
Coinbase will not be in there. It's very common for shared mining pools to not have your Coinbase in there because they're gonna pay you out. They're taking custody of their rewards
and they're going to pay you out,
some percentage,
you know, based on how many shares you've sent. So your your address will not be in the Coinbase. And so
Bidax doesn't know the payout scheme of whatever pool you're connected to. So it could show this warning,
in a case where you're you're mining with a legitimate,
you know, PPL and S or FPVS pool. And actually Where? There was one thing that just came up the other day. Someone was mining to
the two fifty six Foundation pool,
and that warning came up.
Oh, yeah.
Because it's a donation. Because it's a donation. Right? When you mine to the two fifty six Foundation pool,
your address is not in the Coinbase. It's the donation address for February.
So that warning comes up.
We've been working on the wording of it a little bit because
it's not an error. Right? It doesn't if that comes up, it doesn't mean necessarily
that it's a scam.
Right. But Yeah. Because if if you're doing, like, f p or, you know, full pay per share or PPLNS,
they could still be counting your shares.
And in the event of a block find, the pool operator
custodies
that Bitcoin.
And after a 100 confirmations, that Bitcoin becomes spendable
or, you know, when however it gets mixed in with their custodian or whatever, but they make that payout to your address,
and they're paying you out based on
the
contribution you made in proportion to all the hash rate they had at the time of the block find Yeah. In a, like, PPLNS model. Yes. Mean, I you're trusting that they'll do that.
Yeah. So
it's an issue if you really wanna run, like, a no trust kind of setup,
but,
hopefully, you know that this is the case before you join a shared mining pool.
I'm curious. When when you say the it came up the other day with the $2.56
pool,
was
the user surprised to find out that their address was not being included in the Coinbase?
No. They weren't. It actually it's someone who
they totally know what's going on. They just filed, an issue on ESP Miner saying that
maybe we wanna indicate
or have some sort of special exclusion
for two fifty six Foundation.
So they were aware that it's a donation pool. But Okay. They
were just kind of they were kind of
bringing up the fact that it's
a solo mining pool and your Coinbase
or your address is not in the Coinbase.
Right.
We haven't quite figured out how to deal with this because I don't really wanna have special exclusions in the software for any pool.
I think maybe we just need to work on the wording of that warning a little bit. Yeah.
Because I'm I'm wondering if, like, maybe we should update the
the interface. Like, if you go to, like, -.256f.org
where you can see the beautiful dashboard that d plus plus made Huge. For our hosted instance of HydroPool.
Like, it might you know, now that you mentioned it, it might be a good idea for us just to make it clear
somewhere,
like, maybe
somehow that this is
purely a donation
mining pool. I I would just hate for anyone to show up here with the expectation
that in the event of a block find, they're gonna get something out of it.
Yeah.
Yeah. We we should
we we very much should make that
very clear.
Because if someone just
somehow
misses that important fact, then they are going to be very sad.
Right. I mean, I know we have, like, 10,000,000 plus listeners on this show every week.
So you would think it's out there, but we shouldn't make any assumptions. That's true. That's true. Let's leave no stone unturned. Yes.
Let's
yeah. Let's add that. I mean, we can think about where's the right place to add it.
But, yeah, it should be very clear that all proceed you know, you will not get paid out at all. All proceeds from this mining go to the $2.56,
you know Right. Foundation.
Yeah. You just you just point your hash right there because you love us so much.
Which
several people do, and we appreciate them very much.
Yeah.
Right now,
73.5
terahash worth. Boom.
Someone had a lot. There's like a 130
terahash pointed there, like,
around, you know, within the last twelve hours.
Oh, Dee brought up a good point in a comment.
We we have a chat for all of our,
listeners if you go to -.gooskaw56f.org.
And I think you can see it around us right now. But
you can send lightning
to,
you can send a lightning payment of, you know, one or more sats
to, that address. And if you include in your payment a comment,
it will be added to the chat window here. So that's all the the chat that you see is people who have donated sats to a good cause, and they can say something
rad like d plus plus just did.
When she's mentioning that the nerd ack ack nerd ack ackx that solved a block on public pool the other day,
they smashed
the,
the difficulty.
They got,
2,860,
Difficulty?
Yeah. Wasn't it quadrillion?
Yeah. Oh. 200 and
2,860
difficulty
when all you need to get is
a 170.
Wait. 2,000?
That's gotta be, no, like, 2,000 trillion. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There we go. I'll get my units off. It's 2.86 quadrillion
2,860
trillion.
Yeah.
Totally obliterating
the you know, what an overachiever.
Yes.
Which interestingly is not even in the 100
hardest blocks,
the top 100 hardest blocks.
Oh, yeah. We should give what is it? Hardestblocks.org
a shout out? Hardestblocks.org.
Super cool website.
They track the
the biggest overachievers
in Bitcoin mining.
Let's see.
Yeah. Hardestblocks.org.
Looks like block height seven five six nine five one
had a difficulty of 50.54
e as in Quintillion.
Echo. I don't even know what that stands for. That's gotta be
quintillion.
So that's like five
50 that's like 50,000,000
trillion? Yes. 50,000,000 trillion.
Buddy. And does what was the date on that?
That was
10/03/2022.
So the difficulty was probably less than a 100,000,000,000,000 then.
Yeah.
Wow. Yeah. It's a cool website. Fascinating to see all that. They should add actually
I know
the operator of that website is a fan.
Here's a feature request. You should add
what the difficulty was when that block was solved.
You could do like Oh, so you could see how much of an overachiever they are. Of an overachiever they are.
That would be cool to see.
Let's see. I think
there was a recent one September
2025,
so not that long ago.
Oh, here's one in 2026.
It was March 2,
Block height, nine three nine zero zero zero.
Difficulty of 1.51
e. What was that e for again?
That's like exa or quintillion.
So that's million trillion. Quintillion.
Million trillion. Yeah. 1,500,000.
Amazing.
Anyway,
cool stuff. Love to see it.
The guy who runs
Atlas Pool did a cool write up on this too, kinda digging into it. It was more of just an article format of the hardest blocks and how often they got get solved and stuff. It's pretty neat. Check that out.
Awesome.
I was gonna say,
so last week, we got the
we got this the grants renewed for three of the projects.
So,
LibreBoard,
HydroPool,
and Mugena,
have been renewed.
And like I was saying last week, we kinda had to find a happy medium between
the amount of money the foundation has and our ambitions with these projects.
So
right now, we've got a six month commitment
to keep Mugena going
and then a three month commitment to keep LibreBoard and HydroPool going right now.
We will
expand those contingent on getting more funding this year.
But I just wanted to give a quick
update. So on hydro pool,
for the month of April,
we're working on
so do you remember when we did the last telehash,
nice hash
was pointing some hash rate to the tell to our to our
hydro pool instance?
And they send,
like, a difficulty request in the
god. I forget where they put it. In the worker field?
I think they put it in password field.
Password field. That's what it is. Yeah. Yeah.
So our so HydroPool wasn't ready to handle that. So we wanna, like, fix that so that it can handle that if someone is trying to put that flag in the password field.
This is this is a pretty interesting problem.
And I think a lot of pools have this.
Right? So a pool,
they want to set up a steady cadence of how fast you send shares to the pool. So it doesn't matter if you're a nerd miner
or you're a huge mining farm or a mining,
rental.
They want to establish a cadence where, you know, every couple seconds,
the miner sends a share.
And so the way they do that is they say is the it's called the pool minimum difficulty,
and they say to the miner, don't send me a share unless it's above this difficulty.
Yeah. And so the rate at which the miner finds shares above that difficulty depends on the miner's hash rate.
Yep. And so a lot of pools will just have that sort of hard coded where you you you know, when you first establish the connection with the miner over stratum,
you just say,
let's just do minimum difficulty 10,000 or a 100,000 or something.
But the problem is,
you know, a 100,000
is going to be impossible
for a nerd miner to ever hit.
Right. Virtually
impossible.
And it's gonna be
challenging for a bid ax,
but it's gonna be very easy for a mining farm.
And so the mining farm will essentially DDoS
the stratum server by sending so many shares. It's just gonna be like boom boom boom boom boom. Shares super fast.
Meanwhile,
the Bidax is going to not send shares very often, and so your statistics on the mining pool page won't won't look very,
steady.
And it might Like, it'll it'll result in looking like you have a lot less hash rate, right?
Well, it it depends on luck. So it'll it'll kinda jump all over the place. You'll have like, you know, your chart will be lots of up and down.
But yeah, it may take a long time to ramp up to your actual hash rate if they're averaging a lot.
And then it might also just look for a long time like your miner just isn't connected, right? Because they'll they'll have a time out in there where it's like, if I haven't gotten a share from this miner in
thirty minutes or whatever it might be, they'll just assume the miner is disconnected.
They don't know that the miner is still working on,
still working on finding a share that meets the minimum difficulty.
So it's been a problem for pools for a long time. Stratum is a weird archaic Stratum v one is a weird archaic protocol that doesn't have any
Well,
let me back up. Stratum does have a way to deal with this. It's called suggested
difficulty. And that is where the miner tells the pool like, hey, this is what I suggest
you use as the difficulty. Because the miner knows it's hash rate.
So it can tell the pool like, hey, use something like this.
Yeah. And the miner could the pool could just use that and
use that to kinda start its algorithm to find what the ideal
setting is.
The problem is
there's a lot of shitty stratum client implementations out there like Bitmains
that, you know, runs on the majority of miners that does not send suggested difficulty.
So
that's not something that pools can rely on is having the miner
tell the pool where it's at. Like, the bit the the Bidax does,
you know, Mugena does since suggested difficulty, so that's great.
Not all pools
are even programmed to even look at suggested difficulty. A lot of them will just ignore that because they're not even used to getting it.
So that doesn't always work. So
one of the things that these mining rentals do
is they let you put in your hash rate.
The the the
client, the miner,
in your password field, this is password field is almost never used. So you can put in the password field you can put a number and that is your
hash rate or your your your starting difficulty or suggested difficulty
and then the the pool gets that password
and they can use that
as
their starting difficulty. Other pools will have different endpoints. They have like high hash rate endpoints like different URLs like connect to this one if you're a high hash rate, connect to this one if you're low hash rate. That's a pretty crude way to do it.
But, this this
improvement to hydro pool that we're talking about
is
the ability
for the miner to put in their password field their,
like, starting difficulty, their suggested difficulty.
So if you're running like a nerd
miner,
maybe don't use 1234
as your default password. Yeah. Yeah. You actually have to put like D equals, like there's a it's a little bit of like
you you have to put like a parameter.
So just putting a number in there won't screw it up. You have to do like d equals your suggested difficulty.
And then we were actually we had a cool conversation a while back about
we we can definitely accept the d equals in your starting difficulty, but I think a lot of minors might not really know what their their
their
difficulty
their ideal difficulty is.
Yeah. Is it just like a
like a gut feeling? Like, how do you determine? Yeah. Right. There's there's a formula to go from what your hash rate is to how often you might find a share at a difficulty, and you could use that. But, like,
it's it's not as straightforward. So we were talking about adding another parameter that would allow you to put into the password field to put your hash rate.
That's something that most miners would know, your nominal hash rate. So if you have a bit x, you could put like h equals,
you know, 1,200,000,000,000
1.2 terahash per second or something like that.
And so that And then the server can And then the server can do that calculation
for you and figure out what your difficulty should be.
I thought that was pretty neat. It just makes it a little bit easier to do. Less less chance that the miner's gonna screw it up and cause a problem.
Are
are there known servers that can handle that right now, or would that require them to implement this? There are no known servers that support that right now.
But what what this is a hydro pool project, so hydro pool would be the first one to support that.
Yeah. All miners have the password field, so all miners out the gate would support this.
Mhmm.
So it's a
it would be a cool feature for Idrapool to have and, you know, maybe maybe we'd see others adopt it if if it gets some some use. But I know that every telehash we've done, we always have a problem where a big high hash rate miner comes in and it just swamps
our stratum server.
Yeah.
And then there's always kind of this little game of like,
oh, you know, what do you use as a difficulty? Right? If you if you wanna change the pool, like like Dee says, if you wanna set a higher difficulty for a different port, a different URL,
you know, like Right. What what level do you use? You know, how how do you pick that starting difficulty such that the majority of miners will send shares at that rate?
Right. And I think that the having the hash rate field and password, I don't love it because it's the password field. Come on.
But that's what we've got.
You can just put your hash rate in there. And
then
problem solved.
Well and we'll get a chance to test this out again,
I think, May 19
at the Texas Energy and Mining Summit.
Yes. Do I have that date right? Jungly, let's go. Let's get it let's
get it working for that. That'd slick.
Yeah. And, you know, leading up to that, there's some error handling things we wanna button up
just so clients can
kinda know the reason for an issue if there is an issue.
We wanna upgrade the logging system.
And then
it'd be nice to do, like, some benchmarking where we're, like,
using the same hardware to test both
CK pool and HydraPool just to see
how HydraPool is standing up to, like, the industry standard.
Oh, nice. Right? Yeah.
So that's what we're working on
this month in HydroPool.
Mugena,
this is gonna be like
I don't know if universal driver is the right term, but, basically, like, a Bitmain chip driver to cover
the known
Bitmain chips.
So
the ones found in the bit axes,
the Ember one, and the s nineteens.
We've learned a lot about
we've learned a lot about how those work recently, and I think that
with a lot of new information, we could make a pretty rad universal driver
to drive all those chips.
Yeah.
But then that means Mugena can work with any any of those devices.
Right? Like
Yeah. You can figure just, you know,
input the number of chips that you have on your hash board and Yeah. You can get up and running because the hard part's taken care of, which is actually talking with that chip.
Right. Yep.
Lieberboard.
Schnitzel is starting to find a better voltage regulator
instead of the one that is
in the current
version two.
So this is gonna be for version three of the LibreBoard.
We're gonna have some more ideas about that in the next week.
And then
as soon as we have the new voltage regulator defined,
we're gonna update that schematic in the PCB.
And that's gonna change, like, a number of the components and
the leads. What do you call those leads?
Like, connect all the points. Oh, the test points?
No. Not the test points, but, like, the
traces.
Oh, the tray oh, update the board? Yeah. With the Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Some routing.
Route. Yeah. Yeah. Gonna update the routing.
And
then
we'll see.
You know, maybe there's a physical v three coming off the pick and place machine in the near future.
Oh, sign me up. I want one.
Okay.
If you know the guy.
Yeah.
But, yeah, I would like to get that pick and place machine going against it. I should actually be
in a position to
start doing that because I know we wanna get
v six of Ember one
produced so we can validate that design. Yeah. We got a new 6.1, by the way, of Ember one. Okay. 6.1.
So yeah. Yeah. Actually, 6.1
was
largely driven by
features that Ryan discovered while while
developing,
Mugena,
and testing with the v fives that he has.
So
that's been really cool to have,
you know, this conversation with him, you know Right. And
and, you know, see the the practical issues that we have. There was one big bug that he discovered that we've got fixed,
and then there was a couple other
just
reliability
type improvements
that went into 6.1.
Mhmm. So that design
is done and is ready to get manufactured.
See, that's part of the reason I'm such a firm believer that all these projects have to be done in tandem.
Yeah. Like, if, you know, if we were just doing
the Ember one hash board from strictly, like, a hardware design perspective, we're not getting that
insight that Ryan brings to the table from, like, trying to get the firmware to work with it.
And he catches things and looks at it from a perspective that we just don't have looking at it from where we're standing. Right? And that there's, like, crossover between all four of the projects like that. So,
yeah, I just
I think we did a really good job of, like, boiling down what the
very
basic key components of the Bitcoin mining stack are
and turning those into projects and building them in tandem to unlock the whole thing.
Yeah. And it it it already
has spawned
so many new ideas
and little side projects. I think, you know, the all the four projects
sort of when we're talking to one another,
It's all like, oh, we could do that. Let's try that. And,
you know, like Hashscope coming out of Yeah. HydroPool,
like the
the
firmware for the Ember one
that k one made
or that he started as BidX Raw, you know, has spawned a bunch of new ideas on my end.
And,
you know, the CPU miner in Mugena,
just these these kind of things that come along, you know, as you're working on this, you'd be like, that's nice to have. And you can put it out there, and it really moves development forward. And, you know, especially on Regina, right, there's there's become quite the community developing around that GitHub repo of other people working on this and contributing ideas and making improvements and testing things. So
it's
it's very exciting, to say the least. Yeah.
Definitely.
And we've got
I mean, not just that, but we also got, you know, these
people like Brett Rowan contributing
ASIC RS. Oh, yeah. ASIC RS is awesome.
Yeah. And
and now we've got I added, like, a ASIC RS topic in the two fifty six Telegram.
Nice.
So that's got, like, its own topic channel now. If if people wanna learn about ASIC RS
and talk about it and,
you know, just have basic community support, it's there.
Brett has such an amazing understanding of this stuff. Right? And I think, you know, the work the work that he does for his day job, but then also ASIC RS, which has command over all the different miners APIs and all the different configurations of those miners and understanding,
you know, what data they pass back and forth and how they do it. And I think,
he's yeah. I'm I'm super stoked that he's a part of this community and is contributing to this because it it just makes these things better.
Mhmm. Definitely.
How's development
with the Bidax Spoonanza going?
It is it is coming along well. I'm I'm sort of like, fingers crossed,
you know, like, knock on wood. I don't wanna jinx it, but this
this
sort of third major revision of the of the bonanza is working really well.
That's awesome. Yeah. It all came together.
From
soldering all the ASICs
correctly the first time, which I don't think I've ever done before,
to just powering it on and it all just works.
Dude. Yeah. Pretty sturdy. That's huge. Yeah. That's really cool. I'm still waiting for you to tell me who's like, oh, I fucked that up.
You think it's because they are brand new off the reel, the ASIC chips, that you're able to because there wasn't, like, any old solder on them that, like, screwed up the placement.
That definitely helps, but all the Intel chips that we have are like that, and I've I've screwed up soldering them before.
Oh, okay. Okay.
I mean, maybe you're just getting really good at this. You know what? I got
I got that same stencil printer you have.
The Oh, you did? Mhmm.
Do do you like it? I like it.
I like it a lot. And I the first time I used it was for this
for this Bitax Bonanza.
Okay. Then I got it all soldered perfectly the first time. I think it's yeah. I really like it. It took a little bit of playing with it to get it set up just right. And I Yeah.
I took it all apart,
and I tapped,
like, m five
holes.
You know, because that that base plate has all those holes in it
Right. But only some of them are threaded.
So you can only put the mounts in some of the holes that are threaded. Right. Yeah. But I was like, man, it's not enough. Not enough of them are threaded. Like, I I need way more way more
way better positioning ability. So I went and tapped, like, 40 holes.
Oh, no way. So now I can I can thread into everywhere?
That was Smart move. I didn't think about that because I've had such a pain it's been such a pain in the ass to get the
little stands Yeah.
In the right spot. And, usually, like, what's been happening is, like, I'll get all four stands in a place where the pins line up, but then the, like, Allen head is, like, just underneath the edge of the PCB,
and I can't, like, tighten down
the stand.
Yes.
Yeah. It's I got some I got some
thumb screws,
first of all, to to tighten down the
stands.
That really helps. So I can just, you know, do it with my hands.
Okay.
But, you know, what I was having is like, alright. I've got my PCB. I've got all four stands. I've got them I've got it all mounted.
But then
where the openings in the stencil are
is so far off
that I can't use the adjusters. Like the adjusters max out and I can't get it over where it needs to be. And so then I need to move all stands over, but there's no threaded holes.
She's like, all right. I just took the whole thing apart.
I hand tapped that actually was a pain in the ass. But I hand tapped, like, yeah, like, 30 holes.
Yeah. You've gotta get the
the positioning of where the PCB's gonna sit relatively close to where
the stencil's gonna close Yeah.
And have the design because you you are very limited in how far you can go any direction with that.
Yeah. So having more threaded holes helped, especially when I'm doing, like, tiny little PCBs like this. Right? Because it's like Yeah. There's a lot of different places it can be.
So you didn't do, like, a five by 10 grid with those little
I did. I did a two by five panel, but it's still pretty small. Oh, a two by five? Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. JLCPCV
won't make you PCBs this small. You have to panelize them, as I found out. Yeah.
But since this was the first run, I didn't wanna do that many.
So I did whatever the minimum number of panelized parts I could get
to meet their minimum size.
But,
yeah, with with the threaded holes that were on there, was just like I feel like those stands were, like, really splayed out and they were this the thumb screws were already at the ends. So Yeah.
Anyways, I like that. I like that stand. The
what's it called? The
that stencil printer. The brand is
Neoden. Neoden. Yes. Yeah. Yep. I like that.
I had a,
like, a cheaper one before that's, like, really heavy
and it doesn't have
the, like, nice
threaded
rods for,
doing that final positioning.
Oh, yeah.
So How do you get that
that fine to fine adjustment?
Well, it it actually it had
threaded rods for adjusting it, but they were they had so much lash that it was, like, more trouble than it was worth.
Jeez. So I just took that all out, and I would just take the whole plate and just move it.
Oh, no kidding. And then screw it down.
Damn.
What kind of solder paste do you use?
I I still use ChipQuick leaded solder.
Okay.
I have had pretty good results with that, but I'm also not doing, like, anywhere close to production volume.
Yeah. And I also,
like, reorder it from Amazon
probably every quarter.
Okay. Even if, you know, I'm like, the tub is not empty by then, but I'll just get it new. Because when it goes bad, it's it's hopeless.
Oh, does it have a relatively
short shelf life, like like like three months?
It has a sticker on it, and it's you know, the shelf life seems to be, like, eight months, but I have found that it does it doesn't last that long.
Wow. Interesting.
It'll get all, like,
I don't know, just I think that the flux that's in there, like, dries out and it gets really
I don't know. Just chunky peanut It's butter, you like it doesn't Oh, okay. It doesn't spread easily.
Right.
And then it's not gonna solder well.
Yeah. Yeah. You get bridging and tough to get it, like, you know, especially the the openings in the stencils that are really small.
It's tough to get it, you know, evenly in those openings.
And then even when you do, it just doesn't solder well.
Right.
But I
I know you you really like that
that lead free
stuff. Right?
I think it's lead free. I'm trying to remember the name of the website. I think it's
It's like GP or something like that?
No. So okay. So I go to this website called Wave Room Plus.
And on there
let me see. I'm just trying to scroll down and find solder paste
just in case anyone wants to, like, give this stuff a try. I've tried
this solder paste, and it was like a night and day difference over the other stuff I was using. At first, I had bought this crap off of Amazon,
and it was just total garbage. But this stuff is
AIM
m eight. So
a I m m eight. No clean solder paste.
And it does have lead in it. Okay. Tin and lead. Yeah.
Maybe I should try that. Is it super expensive?
Dude, it's like $75
for a little tub of it, and I think it's like
10 ounces.
Let me see.
Oh, it seems like a lot.
10 ounces?
I can't tell how many
how much is in a tub.
Oh, five it's 500 grams. Okay.
So I don't know what that turns into. What
I don't know. The density of that or so.
Yeah.
Alright. Maybe I should give that a try. Because I think the one that you were using before that you didn't like is probably the ChipQuick,
which is just the
the higher end of the Amazon junk.
Okay.
Yeah. Dude, I tried that other stuff and, like,
you know, tried several you know, I would, like, apply it and then inspect it and find that,
you know, it was like
it wasn't staying on the pads where it was supposed to. It was, like, going in between the pads, and I'd, like, wipe it all off, reapply it, try and just get it the best I could to pass a visual inspection. And then even then,
after I would get the components in and then bake it, I would still have all this bridging between the pins and, like,
dude, I just couldn't get it done right. But then I switched to this other stuff and dude, the first time I used it, it just everything just worked the way it was supposed to work.
Love it. It was just night and day difference. That's one of those kinda tools. It's like,
you just pay for it. Because it's like Yeah. Yeah.
Having a good tool
or a good material, I guess, just makes all the difference. And fixing improperly soldered parts is
no kind of fun.
Yeah. No.
No. I'm not set up to be doing any rework. Like, the way my little setup is it's like I it's just meant to like either be done right the first time or, like,
I just need to set it to the side and save it until I can get some rework tools.
But
Even with the real world Let's give a shout out. Yeah. Let's give a shout out to Okay. Our
this so I'm looking at -.256f.org.
And on there, you can find instructions for how to support the show with your hash rate
or donate with Lightning or donate with Bitcoin.
It is a donation pool, so any hash rate you point there
is
for the benefit of the show only. Yes.
This needs to be very clear for all of our users. Right? Yeah. This is a solo mining pool, but you get no you get 0%. We take a 100% fee
for this pool.
It's a solo mining pool with a 100% fee. Yes. But
your fee goes to
directly support
this podcast, the two fifty six Foundation, open source Bitcoin mining, dismantling the proprietary Bitcoin mining empire,
which is a big job, and we really need your support. So
100%.
I was gonna add something else. It
I'll think of I'll I might think of it.
Anyways, this week, we've got Canadian Hash and Coin.
We've got Thack seven seven seven,
Exergy,
Scott nine thousand
coming in with 8.1
terahash. Boom.
Let's see.
I don't see a Bidax Bonanza on there yet,
but I do see a Bidax Turbo Touch.
Yes. I got a Bidax Turbo Touch. It's running a little bit slow right now. Off to
poke at that.
Alright. Alright. Expedition is not quite there yet. Soon. Soon.
Okay. Okay.
We've got hardestblocks.org,
Econo Alchemist, whoever that guy is.
We've got Sarka. Must have a oh, it is. It's a Nerd QX plus plus.
Yep. Crushing it.
Yeah. That's the one that Parasite Pool sent to me. Ah, very cool.
And then I've got a little Bitaxe
sitting up here on the shelf right next to me.
Very nice. And then we've got Zarka.
We've got d plus plus, We've the one who built this
got Schnitzel
hash rate heat punks.
We've got Satoki,
still pointing us hash rate with x x O69.
Very cryptic. I like it.
And we've got, average Bitcoiner
with this worker name, war is gay.
Let's go.
It's a good one. Do you see that oh my god. You must have seen that that Trump video about the gay orgy.
No. What is this? I didn't see it. Oh my gosh. It is the funniest thing I've seen on the Internet in a long time.
It's like a Trump press conference
about
the strike on Iran
and
oh my god.
I'll send it to you after. I'm sure most of our listeners have seen it. It made the rounds. My wife and I were just sitting watching this just absolutely
dying. It's so funny.
The title
of the post is
me talking about
my experience at the gay orgy.
It's so funny. Oh my god.
I think I did see that tweet, but I didn't click on the video. Oh, dude. You need to. It's
hilarious.
And turn the sound up. It's oh my god.
I think it's totally unedited too. It's obviously just a portion of the press conference, but holy. But wait. Is Trump
talk actually talking about that? Or he's, like, talking about
something else, but they're just, like, putting it in that context? Like, he's, like, up there giving a press conference and just the the the portion he's like,
there's all these guys and they know exactly what they're doing and they come fast and they come strong, but they don't all come at once because there's no room. They all come one after another.
Are you talking about, dude?
Brutal.
Oh my god.
Yeah. You gotta pick your words carefully when you're on the world stage, man. Yeah. And then there was the other one the other day where it was on Easter, and he's up on the, like,
the
what is it? The top portico of Oh, the balcony? Yeah. The balcony of the White House, and he's standing next to this very
weird looking Easter bunny costume.
There's like an Easter someone in an Easter bunny costume standing right next to him,
and he's just talking about, like,
war
and striking
and how they're gonna lose and how we're gonna, you know, we're gonna, like, rain down hellfire on them. He's just going on and on, and it's just this, like, Easter bunny standing next to him, like, wide eyed and looking weird.
Dude, what a contrast in, like, the the scenery versus, like, what he's actually saying.
Wild. Yeah. The the the
tweet was pretty funny. It was like
it was like
it was just like oh, man. Was just like, don't feel the brownies.
What what it's like when I just eat like four more brownies or something like that?
God.
It's awesome.
The comedy is just writing itself with this Yes. This is the highest Situation. Best use of the Internet.
Anyways Speaking of wars, Gay. Didn't mean to derail you with all this.
So, yeah, thank you, average Bitcoiner, for that one. We've got Pizzandy.
We've got Backwater Mining Collective.
We got
these guys are challenging me with the enunciation here.
P Buttweiler.
I think I nailed that one. Nice. P Buttweiler. Definitely.
PJBT
nine.
Yeah.
And then we've got
Bitcoin address.
We've got Woodminer,
Western Mass Bitcoin meetup,
and that's all of them.
I wonder if this is like a
a well known
Bitcoin address or something. I'm just gonna put it in mempool.
Space here real quick and see
if this address has any history to it. Maybe they're trying to send us a message. Oh.
Let's see.
It's a whale?
Nope. Never been used.
Alright. Well, mister
eight five r zero t two, you should be aware that you will not be receiving any payout ever to that address.
That's true. Not from this point I should say. Yeah.
Alright.
Well,
next week, stay tuned. We're gonna be one week closer to
the Vegas conference.
One week closer to the next Telehash in Austin, Texas.
Closer to the next Telehash.
You're gonna be in Vegas,
and so are a number of other two fifty six
foundation
contributors
doing a number of panels,
bringing the signal among a sea of noise.
Yes. I'm looking forward to We're
also gonna be on the HRF
Freedom Go Up stage,
the whole two fifty six crew that'll be there.
Awesome. We're gonna go on, yeah, on the HRF stage. That should be pretty neat. Just dive a little bit deeper into the two fifty six topics.
Great. That should be fun.
Oh, I also want to shout out,
on the twentieth of this month on 04/20,
I am going to be in Nashville at Bitcoin Park. We're doing a mining
mining Mondays meetup.
Oh, awesome. Yeah. Good. Yeah. That should be pretty cool.
You know, if you're in the area, stop by and, check it out. We're gonna,
you know, talk about all all things all things mining,
but probably get into home mining,
get into
what Bitcoin miners are actually doing so that you can start hacking on them.
Mhmm. And any other topics that come up should be pretty fun.
Awesome.
I'm glad you guys are still doing that.
Yeah. Yeah. Me too. We wanted to get it going. We're actually we're gonna do it,
last month,
on the third Monday, but
there was, like, some big storm and all the flights got canceled, so it didn't happen. But Oh, bummer.
It's gonna happen this month, weather pending.
Okay. Cool.
Good. And then,
yeah, I guess that's it for now.
You
know what we were gonna talk about?
I don't know if our producer extraordinaire Dee is still here, but she was gonna tell us about this amazing change that she made to the
HydroPearl dashboard.
Oh, yeah. Dee, are you in here?
Yes. Alright. There you are. You were telling us earlier when we were in the Green Room before
the broadcast started about
a pretty cool change that you made or pretty funny, I guess, change that you made to the dashboard. So just so just so
oh, really? Oh, really?
You don't come through on the livestream?
Bummer. So we're just
nobody knows who we're
okay. Producer DJ Extraordinaire just informed us that
we can hear her, but no one else can. So
maybe I'll just summarize it.
Unless you want you wanna summarize the the chain?
Okay.
So if you go to -.256f.org,
there's a fantastic dashboard that D plus plus made.
It really
leveled up our game here
with with the dashboard thing. It looks fantastic. We use it behind the scenes at this show to credit our hashers.
But one of the things that it shows is the number of blocks that we've solved.
I guess that's in the
dashboard portion that she made for the telehash.
It shows the number of blocks solved. And this isn't just like
some,
you know,
what is it? Just some proprietary
database where we just trust
how many blocks we've solved.
It actually scans the blockchain to see how many blocks have been pointed how many blocks have been solved and paid out to the donation address.
And,
anyways, that's one because we we solved the block live on stage at the first telehash.
Mhmm. But
the the question was, you know, at future telehashes, we don't wanna
show that we've already solved the block on stage.
We want it to be zero. So she actually has it hard coded in there. Number of blocks found minus one.
Yeah. It's on the
it's on the oh, it should be on the overlay for the livestream. Yes. On the Is it on the overlay for livestream?
Yeah. Okay.
Maybe it should be one.
I I mean, we did find one.
Well That's true. We are. We are. But,
I mean, I think I think the
so Dee said we want people to think that we're poor, and I I think we we do a good job of comparing that.
So I
think people can read between the lines. People can read between the lines. Yeah. So I guess we gotta decide
for the overlay at the telehash
when we start it, you know, like when it first starts, do we wanna already have it say we've solved one block, or is it like
the podcast also has the number zero. Does it have it
on the dash two?
Oof.
Okay. So
the dashboard also has a number of blocks found and has the
hard coded minus one. You know, this this could be a problem though because we're gonna be solving,
I don't know, probably 10 blocks at the next telehash.
So you're gonna have to stay on top of this hard coding. It might be better to just
put the number of blocks, and if we have to explain it, we can explain it.
Yeah. We're gonna lose count of the number of blocks we found here pretty soon. I know. We're gonna overflow
uint 64.
You know, this this is a real we need to think long term here.
That's right.
Alright. Well, until next week.
This is two this is pod two fifty six signing off,
and we'll see y'all next time. See you next time. Thanks, everyone.